[music]
>> I'm feeling very happy, glad for you
all. Alhamdulillah. And masha Allah,
today we have extended the session
by 4 hours and alhamdulillah, yet no
signs of tiredness seen. Alhamdulillah.
And this is
the biggest positive that which I've
realized
working specially with Dr. Zakir Naik.
You realize that you have much more
potential than what you think about
yourself.
And Zakir bhai has that
technique
to take out the most, the best in you.
And alhamdulillah, I take this
opportunity to thank Allah subhana wa
ta'ala for whatever he has given me in
the span of 8 years I worked with IRF
and special thanks to Dr. Zakir Naik
because it is he who has taken out this
potential in me. I wasn't
you know, anywhere close to it. So,
jazakallah Dr. Zakir Naik.
So, the homework, revision of the
Quranic verses,
those verses which are helpful for your
dawah talks.
So, the heading itself
is so clear
and it's so important that as a day
you would be
and
it should be a piece of cake for you. A
cake walk.
That you have to remember these
references similar to the way as you're
remembering masha Allah the surah names.
With speed.
So, this
12 sets of verses that we have,
it should be the best.
No compromise.
Inshallah.
To begin with,
out of the 20 participants seated here,
how many of you have learned all the 12
sets of verses? Please raise your hand.
When I say verses, please
know that it includes both Arabic as
well as the English.
All the 12 sets of verses,
verses which are helpful for dawah
talks.
1 2 3
Arabic and English both, brother Sabu.
Inshallah.
Four of you.
Masha Allah.
The rest?
How many of you have learned 10?
10 out of 12, both the Arabic as well as
the English translation.
Masha Allah, one brother, brother Imran,
10 verses
with Arabic and English.
Sorry?
Inshallah. Okay.
Nine verses, Arabic and English out of
the 12, nine?
Eight?
Masha Allah.
Three brothers.
So, we have eight,
three brothers,
10 one and all 12 sets we have masha
Allah four.
Seven?
How many brothers for seven?
Masha Allah. Only one?
Only one?
Confident?
Inshallah. Very good. So, we have two
brothers who have learned seven out of
12 sets of verses.
>> [laughter]
>> Allahu Akbar.
So, I've already got your feedback. It's
only one verse that which you have
learned. Subhan Allah.
So, only one brother seven, six?
Six verses?
Nobody? 50%?
You know, at least we expected
that the participants would be able to
reach 50%.
Five?
Four?
Three?
Three verses? Masha Allah, brother Atik.
Three verses only one?
25%?
Anyone learning less than 25% is not
even worth being asked for.
The homework
which was given to you 2 weeks before,
it had
not less than 90 verses.
And that was the homework which you were
supposed to do while you were in your
own home countries
before you landed in Mumbai.
Not less than 90 verses which were given
to you.
But yesterday's homework was so simple
and so easy.
Only 12 sets of verses.
And that too
which are helpful for your dawah talks.
It's unacceptable.
Two?
And Abu Shareef has already given his
one.
Okay, brother Omar Yusuf,
for learning the 12 sets of verses, how
much time did you spend?
Please, the participants as well as me
would like to know. For learning the 12
verses, Arabic and English, how much
time did you spend?
Uh actually, I had a memory of all the
verses that I've memorized already, but
I need to revise a little bit and uh go
through the translation a little.
Okay. So, it took me about roughly when
I was back home, I I took about
half an hour, 45 minutes.
Half an hour to 45 minutes.
Masha Allah. When I came here yesterday
at night, I was like How many minutes?
I was revising the lesson with my
Mhm. How many minutes? minutes
We just learned the lesson in the
previous session, to be specific.
Half an hour?
Half an hour. Half an hour.
So, earlier you had given half an hour
to 45 minutes and yesterday
or today morning? Yes, or yesterday?
Yesterday. Yesterday you gave another
half an hour. So, it took 1 hour
for you to learn 12 sets of verses,
Arabic with English translation.
So, I would like to ask the
participants,
the rest who did not learn the 12 sets
of verses, couldn't you spare 1 hour
for the cause of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
to learn the Quranic verses with the
translation?
Okay, brother masha Allah may be good at
it. So, he took 1 hour.
At least 2 hours?
You're learning the Quranic verses.
Besides getting the sawab, you know,
there is also a sawab
in learning the Quranic verses in
Arabic. If you recite, you know, while
you're learning it, you recite it
multiple times.
So, every time you're reciting every
single letter of the Quran, you're
getting the sawab.
Couldn't you spare 2 hours?
The striving and struggling
that which you do in the cause of Allah,
I guess this needs
the most attention from you all.
That you're learning the Quran,
the book of Allah,
with its translation, with the
references.
Brother Ahmed Shafiq, how many?
How many verses have you learned?
I've tried to do all of them, but
inshallah, so far seven is Sorry?
I've tried memorizing all of them, but
if you want to count like the number
verse,
around seven, roughly seven. Okay, you
gave me a clue for another question to
ask.
How many of you tried learning all the
verses
and are at least 80% accurate? 80%?
All 12 sets of verses with the Arabic
and English.
And I presume that the four brothers who
had raised their hands earlier, they
know alhamdulillah 100% or at least 90%.
Even 10% if they make mistakes,
agreeable.
At least 90% Farik?
Or 100%?
Okay.
More than 90% inshallah.
It can be 99, 92, more than 90%.
Okay, masha Allah. So, you're confident
about 90?
You're confident about 90%?
Inshallah.
Brother Yusuf?
85%?
Brother Ash?
Above 90%?
Masha Allah. Brother Sabu?
90% Inshallah. 90%?
So, two brothers, actually three,
if you include 90 as well,
are confident
that the 12 sets of verses that which
they have learned,
they remember the accuracy is 90% and
above, Inshallah.
60%?
I asked 80, nobody raised their hand.
60?
All 12 sets of verses?
Brother, you know 10 verses, 10 verses
you know 100%, right?
Inshallah.
How many of you spent at least an hour
for learning the Quranic verses, please
raise your hand. At least an hour.
An hour.
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9.
So, nine of you spent, and minus brother
Iman,
eight of you
spent at least an hour, and you were
unable to learn even one verse,
Arabic and English translation?
It's amazing.
One verse,
Arabic,
with the translation and the reference,
were you unable to learn in 1 hour?
Eight participants?
Brother Kamaruddin Abdullah, please pass
on the microphone to him.
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykumu s-salam
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Brother
Kamaruddin, tell me honestly,
how much time would you take to learn
one verse with the reference, Arabic and
English?
If it's a short one like
wa qalu lan yadkhula l-jannata illa man
kana hudan aw nasara,
roughly 1 hour. 1 hour? I will put it
practice practice practice on.
And then I will use it in the field. Who
can beat brother Kamaruddin Abdullah
taking less time?
Brother Kamaruddin Abdullah says
to learn the verse of Surat al-Baqarah,
chapter number two, verse number 111.
Yes, sir. He says that he takes 1 hour.
Who can beat brother Kamaruddin Abdullah
to learn this one verse
with the Arabic and English
less than an hour?
One.
Two.
Three. Four.
One verse, reference, Arabic, and
English translation.
30 minutes?
One verse,
reference, Arabic, and English
translation. 30 minutes.
30 minutes, 3 0, not 1 3.
To learn one verse with Arabic and
English translation along with the
reference.
Brother Ash, only one.
Short piece?
Wal asr, by the token of time.
>> [laughter]
>> How short?
Or qaf, Arabic letter qaf.
Huh? How much time would you take?
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]
>> Allah.